Transcriber: Aybüke Ekiz
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
[Müzisyen Anne]
Tek isteğimiz bir kardeş yapmaktı.
Bu kadar gidilmeyen yollara
savrulacağımızı bilmeden
ama bilseydik de giderdim
çünkü çocukluğumdan beri
gidilmeyen yollara gitmekle meşhurdum.
Mesela konservatuvara girmek.
Doksan bir yılında
herkes Anadolu Lisesi'ne girerken,
kolej sınavlarına hazırlanırken,
konservatuvara gitmek istedim.
Ailem destek oldu, çalıştım, kazandım.
Herkes gurur duyuyordu,
kuafördeki teyzeler hariç.
Onlar anneme sorduğunda annem gururla:
"Konservatuvarı kazandı."
"Olsun, işte, neyse artık."
çünkü onlar için
o yılda gidilmeyen bir yoldu.
Konservatuvarda okumak tuhaf gelmişti.
On yaşında bir çocuk
Maltepe'den Beşiktaş'a gidip gelecekti.
Ortaokul, lise, üniversite yıllarını
konservatuvarda bitirdim.
Çok kolay, çok başarılı
bir öğrencilik yılım olmadı
ama o diplomayı ite kaka,
düşe kalka da olsa aldım
çünkü aileme bir söz vermiştim,
gidilmeyen bir yola çıkmıştım
ve o yol bitecekti.
Derken,
çok başına buyruk bir gençlik yaşarken
kavga ile otobüste eşimle tanıştım.
Herkes dedi ki "Tuhaf bir ilişki,
nasıl olsa ayrılırlar."
Temmuz ayında on yıllık evli olacağız.
(Alkış)
Benim karakterimde biri için evlilik bile
çok büyük bir gidilmeyen yoldu
çevremdeki herkes adına.
Derken,
evliliğimizin ilk yılında
yurt dışından anne-çocuk müzik okulu
buldum.
Bunu Türkiye'ye getirip Türkiye'de kurmaya
karar verdim.
Yine çevremdeki insanlara
bir heves anlattığımda
"Ya, Ahu işte." tepkilerini aldım.
"Tabi yaparsın, aslansın,
bunu da kıvırırsın!" kimse demedi.
Annem, babam destek oldu.
Kayınvalideme anlattım.
"Tabii kızım." dedi
ama şimdi itiraf ediyor,
"Hadi inşallah"mış o "Tabii"si.
Şimdi on yıllık Türkiye'nin ilk ve tek
ve hâlâ tek rakipsiz
anne-bebek müzik okulunun sahibiyim.
(Alkış)
Okulu kurduğumuz ilk sene
Lâl Prenses aramıza katıldı.
Sürpriz bir hamilelik,
çok sağlıklı geçen bir hamilelik
ve hâlâ Allah nazardan saklasın
yedi yıldır bize hiçbir sorun çıkarmayan
çok güzel bir prensesin annesiyim.
Derken, tabii her anne gibi, her baba gibi
kardeş yapma fikri aklımıza girdi
ve eşime dedim ki:
"Lâl Prenses doğduğu sene
çok borcumuz vardı,
iş yerimizi yeni kurmuştuk,
lütfen maddi manevi
en hazır olduğumuz dönemde
kardeş yapalım."
Eşim tuhaf karşıladı
ama kadınsal istekler oluyor.
Maalesef hastane odasını süsletelim,
fotoğrafçı çağıralım,
"Sağlıklı olsun da!" kısmını hep
maalesef geride mi bırakıyoruz?
Heves ediyoruz.
Sosyal medyanın kandırmacasına
kurban gidiyoruz.
Derken, hamile kaldım
ve o yoğun çalışma temposunda
domuz gribi olup komaya girdim.
Yirmi bir haftalıktı
bebeğimizi kaybettiğimizde
ve o çok hayalini kurduğum
erkek bebeğin yolda olduğunu,
kaybettiğimizi öğrendik.
Çok erkek bebek isteme sebebim
cinsiyet ayrımı değildi.
"Yılmaz" koyacaktım adını
çünkü babama çok hayranım,
"Yılmaz" koymak
ve çok fanatik olduğum takım
"Yılmaz Kartal" koymak istiyordum ismini.
Bir yıl sonra Yılmaz Kartal'ın
yolda olduğunu öğrendik.
Dedim ki "Mucize, Allah bana acıdı,
dileklerimi kabul etti."
O an şunu öğrendim,
doğru niyet etmek önemliymiş.
Hep şunu dedim aileme de
"Öyle bir anda
anne olmak istiyorum ki tekrar,
sadece bebeğime ben bakayım,
kimse ellemesin, bakıcılar büyütmesin.
Maddi manevi ne gerekiyorsa karşılayayım."
ve oğlum oldu, yirmi aydır benim dışında,
hemşirelerin dışında
istesem de kimse bakamıyor zaten.
Olsun, dedim ki, "Allah beni kırmadı,
bir erkek bebek gönderdi,
demek ki bu bir sınav."
"Ben sana veriyorum istediğini
ama baş edebilecek misin Ahu?"
Kartal on dokuz günlüktü
yoğun bakıma kaldırıldığında.
Çok sağlıklı bir hamilelik
ve bebek olarak dünyaya geldi
ancak yoğun bir şekilde
solunum yetmezliğiyle
hastane kaldırdığımızda
kalbinin mikrop kaptığını
ve kalp kası zedelenmesiyle
kalp yetmeziliği oluştuğunu öğrendik.
Olsundu, para kazanmıştık,
tedavi ettirebilirdik,
aklım fikrim parada hâlâ,
hep böyle
para her şeyi çözermiş gibi düşünüyorum.
Doktor çıktı,
"Maalesef" dedi, "Durumu iyi değil."
Dedim: "Ne olabilir en kötü?"
"En kötü", dedi "kalp nakli."
Hâlâ olayın bilincinde değilim
çünkü sizin hiç yirmi günlük bebeğinize
"Kalp nakli olması gerekiyor."
denildi mi?
Benim çevremde kimseye denilmemişti.
Döndüm Levent'e,
"Yaptırırız değil mi?"
Yaptırırız, yani adam da ne desin şimdi?
Lohusayım.
Bundan altı ay önce
kucağı boş bir lohusalık yaşamışım.
Şimdi on dokuz günlükken
yine kucağı boş bir lohusalık yaşıyorum.
Doktor dedi ki:
"Ahu Hanım,
öyle yaptırırız demekle olmuyor.
"Maalesef ülkemizde henüz
bu kadar ufak bebeklere
kalp nakli yapıldığını hiç görmedim."
"İlk oluruz!" dedim.
Adamcağız idare etmeye çalışıyor
ama "Keşke" dedi,
"Organ bağışı olsa ve nakil yapılsa."
Çevrenizde hiç kadavradan kalp nakli,
organ nakli bekleyen
bir yakınınız, çocuğunuz oldu mu
bilmiyorum ama,
duası olmayan tek hastalık.
Ne diyecektim ki?
"Allahım, bize bir kalp ver!" demek
ne demek biliyor musunuz?
"Birini öldür de o kalp bize gelsin"
demek
ve o ölecek kişinin de
maalesef ki bir çocuk olması lazım.
Sen, anne olarak çocuğunu kurtarmak için
"Başka bir annenin çocuğu ölsün."
diyebilir misin?
Nasıl dua edeceksin ki?
"Bir mucize olsun!" dedim ne olur,
bir mucize olsun, şifasını gönder.
Mucize yola çıktı gibi oldu,
ilaç tedavimiz başladı,
ilaçlarla düzelir gibi olduk.
Sekiz aylıkken doktor dedi ki,
"Hayır, olmuyor, yetmiyor, kalp nakli."
Dedim "ama olmaz demiştiniz!"
Olmaz.
Almanya'daki hastaneyi bulduk.
Çocuğu yoğun bakıma kaldırmıştık,
kötüleşmişti.
İmzalarla çıkardık, serumlarla apar topar
ekonomi uçağıyla Almanya'ya uçurduk.
Oradaki doktorlara göstermek istedik.
Turistik vizeyle elinde serumla
hastaneye giren ilk insanız herhalde.
Doktorlar dedi ki:
"Maalesef, çok kötü,
göründüğünden de kötü.
Bu çocuk bu kadar iyiyse
belli ki çok neşeli bir annesiniz.
İyi bakmışsınız. Hayat aşılamışsınız
ama ölmek üzere."
Dedim, "Burada kalalım.
Burada nakil yapın."
"Hayır, yapamayız, prosedür gereği
Almanya'da size nakil yapamayız."
"Ama Kartal'ın ateşi var." dedim,
sanırım enfeksiyon kaptı uçaktan.
Kızdılar, "Enfeksiyon tedavisi yapalım,
gidin." dediler.
O gece
benim için gidilmeyen yol kapandı mı?
Hayır.
Levent'e döndüm, dedim ki,
çok dehşet verici bi cümle ama,
"Evlatlık verelim mi?"
Almanya'da yaşayan,
o hastanede tedavi ettirebilecek
bir aile bulalım, verelim.
Yeter ki yaşasın.
Ben doğurdum, ben yaşatamıyorsam
başka biri yaşatsın
ama yaşadığını bileyim.
Eşim "Saçmalama." dedi
ama birkaç saat sonra mantıklı geldi.
Bütün gece, sabaha kadar
prosedürleri araştırdık.
Tabii, böyle bir şeyin çok zor olacağını,
hatta yasal olmayacağını,
daha fena
başımızın belaya girebileceğini düşündük.
Ertesi sabah yine bir mucize oldu.
Baş hekim bizi çağırdı.
"Çocuğunuzu kabul edeceğiz
ama bir milyon yüz bin avronuz var mı?"
dedi.
Şimdi, adam kabul edeceğiz dedikten sonra
"Yok." diyemedik.
"Var." dedik.
Adam da saçımız başımız düzgün diye
herhalde inandı.
"Tamam o zaman" dedi, "Getirin,
kalp nakil listesine alacağım."
O süreçten sonra işte
bizim paniğimiz başladı.
Valilik izinleri, prosedürler,
sağlık bakanlığından onaylanması...
Onay çıktıktan sonra
sadece on dokuz saat sürdü
bir milyon yüz bin avronun toplanması.
Bu da bir mucizeydi.
On dokuz günlük bebeğimiz,
on dokuz saatte toplanan para...
On dokuzun mucizesi
bu şekilde gidiyordu
ama o para da Kartal'ı kurtarmadı işte,
çünkü on dokuz saatte toplanan para
on dokuz günde o kalbi getirmedi.
Dört ay daha bekledi Kartal o şekilde.
Tam üç kere bize
"Bebeğiniz ölüyor, hazırlanın." dediler.
Herkes hazırlandı, ben hazırlanmadım.
"Be kadın, isyan etmedin mi?"
demiyor musunuz?
Bir kere ettim.
On altı ağustos sabahı.
Kartal'ın birinci yaş doğum günü.
Doktorlardan izin aldım,
bekleme odasında
doğum günü partisi yapacağım.
Gece bütün odayı süsledim,
sabah pastasını getireceğim.
Doktor bizi yanına çağırdı,
"Kartal, beyin kanaması geçiriyor." dedi.
"Yani?" dedim.
"Sağ ayağı ve sağ kolu felç oldu." dedi.
"Tamam." dedim, "Yani?"
"Kanama ilerlerse" dedi,
"nakil listesinden çıkaracağım."
Hiçbir şey diyemedim.
İlk defa çok çaresiz hissettim.
O zamana kadar "Hayır gitmeyecek,
bırakmayacak." derken
yoğun bakım merdivenlerine oturdum,
eşimi eve yolladım.
Sadece bağırmaya başladım.
"Git" dedim, "Git artık."
"Benim için kalma!
Baban için de kalma.
Biz her şeye razıyız.
Eğer çok acı çekiyorsan
ve biz üzüleceğiz diye kalıyorsan
git anneciğim
ama kalmayı tercih edersen de
ben sana ömür boyu bakacağım.
Yarın senin doğum günün,
istersen bir kere daha doğ,
bir daha başlayalım."
Sabah geldiğimde
Kartal'ın kanaması durmuştu.
Kalp nakil listesinden çıkmamıştı.
"Bu" dedim, "bir mesaj bize."
Bir daha başlıyoruz.
Yıkılmak yok.
Gitmediysen kalmayı tercih ettiysen
beni duydun ve kalacaksın.
Bu süreçte sosyal medyanın desteğini
para toplarken gördüğüm kadar
maalesef manevi olarak
çok zorluklarını da çektim.
Şahit olanlarınız olmuştur.
Para verdiğimiz için,
yardım topladığımız için
Kartal'ı ve beni
herkes satın almış gibi davrandı.
"Biz sana para verdik,
bunu yazamazsın!"
Kartal'ın resmini koymadığın gün olmaz."
"Hayvan olsa senin yaptığını yapmaz,
nasıl gülebiliyorsun
çocuğun yoğun bakımdayken?"
"...çünkü biz sana para verdik."
Kenetlendiğimiz kadar
anında bölünebildiğimizin de şahidi oldum.
"Çok etkilendiysen
sosyal medyaya ara ver." dediler.
Vermeyeceğim ara!
Sizin için, biliyor musunuz?
Şuradaki seyircilerden bir tanesinin
bebeğine kalp nakli gerekirse diye
ara vermiyorum.
Ben onca hakarete,
onca şeye göğüs gerebilirim
çünkü bende bu güç var
ama size nakil gerektiğinde
o kalbin bulunması için
bana da ihtiyaç var.
Bu bilince ihtiyaç var,
organ bağışına ihtiyaç var bu ülkede.
Buna inanıyorum.
Bunu biliyorum.
Eminim bu bilincin yerleşeceğine.
Kimsenin bizim gibi gidilmeyen yollara
savrulmayacağını ilerki günlerde
biliyorum
ve sizden şunu istiyorum:
Kimseyi acılarınızla karşılaştırmayın.
Herkesin sınavı kendine ağır.
Sizin patronunuz kızmış olabilir,
eşinizle sorununuz olabilir,
maddi sorunlarınız olabilir.
Bu sınav da benim sınavım.
Bana ağır gelmiyor.
Zor ama ağır değil
çünkü benim evladım
ama siz yazarken
"Ben olsam ölürdüm." yazıyorsunuz.
Sen olmayacağını yarın nereden biliyorsun?
Başınıza geldiği zaman
her şeye katlanabiliyorsunuz.
Gerçekten ama "Niye?" değil.
"Neden benim oğlumun başına bu geldi?"
demedim.
"Kimin ahını aldım, kime ne yaptım da
Kartal'a bu oldu?" demedim.
Ben kendimi biliyorum.
Ben iyi bir insan olduğumu düşünüyorum,
Allah'ın takdiridir
ama insan seviyorum, kendimi seviyorum,
sizi seviyorum, doğayı seviyorum,
yaşamayı seviyorum, oğlumu seviyorum,
kızımı seviyorum. Herkesi çok seviyorum.
Önce Allah "Bitti." der,
sora anne "Bitti." der.
Ben Allah "Bitti." demediği sürece
"Bitti" demedim.
Bitmeyecek de, bu yol uzun sürecek.
Oğlum kalp nakli oldu
ama savaşımız uzun yıllar devam edecek.
Bebeklerde yapılan kalp naklinin
yirmi, yirmi beş yıl sonra
tekrarlanması gerektiğini
Almanya'da öğrendik.
Korkmuyorum.
Teknoloji gelişiyor.
Başımıza ilerde neler gelebilecek
bilmiyoruz
ama her gün
"Ya bir daha nakil olursa?"
korkusuyla da yaşamak istemiyorum.
Siz de bu korkuyla yaşamayın.
"Ya yarın ölürsem?" diye yaşıyor muyuz?
Yaşamıyoruz.
Lütfen
karşınıza gidilmeyen bir yol çıktığında
o yolun kenarında durup
hayatınızı izlemeyin.
Şoka girmeyin.
Erken teşhis kadar
erken müdahale de önemli.
Hayatınızın direksiyonuna geçin.
Nereye sürdüğünüz çok önemli.
Lütfen uçurumlara sürüklenmeyin.
Herkes dedi "Canın yanmıyor mu?"
Yanıyor.
"Kahrolmuyor musun?"
Oluyorum
ama bitmedi ki.
Ben, "Son nefesimi oğlum verene kadar
kendimi yerden yere atmayacağım." dedim.
Atmadım da.
Vermedi de, çok şükür
ama şunu size söyleyebilirim ki:
Yorgunum, özlüyorum hayatımı
ve insanın başına ne zaman
nerede ne geleceği hiç belli olmuyor.
Doğru niyet edin.
Kimseyi kınamayın.
Kınadığınız yaşamadan ölmediğinizi
ben birebir yaptığım hatalarla görüp
ders almış bir anneyim.
Çok insan kınayan,
çok nefret saçan,
aslında kavga eden bir insan
hiçbir zaman olmadım
ama kendime aldığım dersler çok büyük.
Yirmi aydır yaşadığım süreci
müsaadenizle
Mevlana Celaleddin Rumi'nin
dizeleriyle size aktararak
veda etmek istiyorum:
Allah der ki “Kimi benden çok seversen
onu senden alırım.”
...Ve ekler: "Onsuz yaşayamam" deme,
seni onsuz da yaşatırım.
Ve mevsim geçer,
gölgesini veren ağaçların dalları kurur,
sabır taşar, canın saydığın yâr bile
gün gelir el olur, aklın şaşar.
Dost dediğin düşmana dönüşür,
düşman kalkar dost olur,
öyle garip bir dünya.
Olmaz dediğin ne varsa olur...
“Düşmem” dersin düşersin,
”Şaşmam” dersin şaşarsın.
Ve ne gariptir ki “Öldüm” der durur,
yine de yaşarsın.
(Alkış)